goldman sachs gets even gloomier on the
u.s economy cnn goldman sachs is
becoming increasingly pessimistic about
the u.s economy as chronovirus support
from the government phases out and
consumer spending remains on an
uncertain path over the weekend the wall
street bank downgraded its forecast for
america's economic growth which is
closely monitored by the investment
community goldman sachs now expects the
economy to expand 5.6 this year compared
to a previous 5.7 percent estimate in
2022 uh 5.7 in 2022 growth is projected
to expand
four percent down from 4.4 it is the
second time goldman sachs has revised
its 2021 forecast lower in two months
goldman sachs also thinks spending could
decline as people could continue to work
from home encouraging them to prepare
their own lunches instead of popping
into a local restaurant so that's
goldman okay that's what gold now you're
laughing you have a comment you have
thoughts yeah i just it's so obvious
this and even it's coming from cnn but
this is this is how media works the
headline
like if you actually look at the numbers
you want to talk persona versus policy
goldman sachs predicts an even gloomier
look on the outcome goldman sachs has
predicted 5.6
down from 5.7 oh my god point one
percent that's not a big number what are
we talking about here's a question yeah
it would your point would make sense if
it said fox news instead of cnn why cnn
telling this story headlines
again i don't know i'm not even worried
about cnn i don't agree right 5.7 was
glued down from the six point two yeah
so it's that's five point six five six
point two yeah so well this is this
point four percent to four percent
that's ten percent that's a real number
so that part's a real number it's like
11 you're talking about with a number
like that so look they're not optimistic
about the economy so what happens if the
economy takes a hit the next 12 18 24
months does mid years take a massive hit
for the left midterms midterms
oh i i don't think that i give the
probably 80 chance republicans take
control of the house or win the midterms
for sure i mean that's that's not even
the current climate that's just politics
in general the the party that's not in
power takes over them
in the midterms that i mean you probably
have a very clear example of this but i
think republicans will take over in the
midterms
yeah uh well look man
who knows the um
there's so much there's so much
redlining there's so much gerrymandering
that there's there's so much happening
behind the scenes that i don't i don't
want to get too in depth on people but i
mean look 20 we talk about uh we talk
about the um what was the recall
election in california we talked about
that a lot right
something that we didn't really discuss
in depth was the demographics of the
voters in that right 25
25 a full quarter of the voters uh were
from citizens naturalized citizens born
outside the country so
you know what's happening at the
southern border what's happening across
you know red states what's happening in
these environments that uh people are
leaving right so like where are your
swing states where are your swing states
where are your swing demographics
there's nobody regardless of anything or
any policies anything that the biden
administration can do there's no
republican or libertarian or independent
that's ever going to win
really ever again probably in my
lifetime in new jersey and new york and
michigan
and i mean they've gotten maybe michigan
it's going to be very why is that what's
the cause of that because at the end of
the day everyone gets one vote political
strategy so one of the reasons again
these people are not stupid right the
people running these places are not
stupid
phil murphy let's just use jersey for an
example this guy that name this guy no
don't say that name gerard he knows
exactly what he's doing he knows that
people are leaving his state all right
he knows five years in a row new jersey
has left
has led the nation and people leaving
his state this literally his population
is telling him i would rather live
anywhere else but with you that should
be in in a normal governing environment
that should be a massive red flag that
our policies aren't working instead the
policies are working to their end where
they have nothing but their voters left
so in these places a lot of precedent
that we had before people couldn't pick
up and leave with their oregon trail
times you know just because they didn't
like herbert humphrey they weren't
hopping on a you know horse and buggy
and
hightailing it 3 000 miles south now you
can so a lot of a lot of what's
happening now in politics a lot of
what's happening behind the scenes you
can't look at past analytics they're not
predictive at this point right they the
democratic party specifically has done
two things they are a big tent party
they they are the party of yes and
juxtaposed themselves against
republicans which are the party of no
okay anything you want yes absolutely 75
genders of course there are the gas and
the brakes
yeah they're the party of yes okay
and
what they do is once they have control
they squeeze out all opposition small
business get the f out don't watch you
you small business owners you guys are
gone you guys are our opposition
independent voters gone get out of here
i want a constituency of nothing but
union members teachers cops that's it
all right i want i want there to be
three shops i want amazon and every
freaking corner that's that's their
strength i think small small business
owners got to stop bitching that's what
they got to do they got to figure it out
i think small business owners if they
can't pay the minimum wage you know to
people they got to pay them higher hey
man you got to compete so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]